from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host today joined
by ramsay personality and best-selling
author christina ellis and we are
excited to take your call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll talk about your life your
money
the economy what you're worried about
what you're excited about we'll
celebrate your wins
we'll help you walk through whatever
you're walking through we are here for
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five joseph kicks us off in grand
junction colorado joseph welcome to the
show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can we help
so my question for today i started
working for
the colorado parks and wildlife and i'm
17 and was wondering if i should start a
401k and how much i should be
contributing
uh putting into that that's awesome man
well congrats on the gig that's
fantastic do you have any debt thank you
uh i do not have any debt i
i love everything that you guys teach
and i've uh followed all the baby steps
and
uh so far i'm i have my emergency fund
and all of that so wow that's incredible
at 17 how did you find out about this
stuff uh
my parents have taken your class and
when i was a freshman in high school i
started uh
i took your guys's adult class and i
just kind of like man this is pretty
awesome i enjoy this so i've just uh
throughout the many years uh
uh listened and tried to
see how to manage my money best you are
wise beyond your years joseph we love to
hear it so uh go ahead christina is this
the job that you want to do long term uh
yes ma'am i am pursuing a game warden
which is also part of the
parks and wildlife so i started a
maintenance job with them until i could
possibly pursue that is there any
further education that you're going to
need any college or anything that will
cost money to get educated
yes with the
pursuing game warden you need a
biology degree and i'm pursuing fish and
wildlife biology and that's a four-year
degree
that's awesome when does that start
uh i'm already taking college classes
because of the cheap costs with being a
high schooler
and i'm going to a community college to
get all my
gen classes done and then i'm going to a
university to
take the major
classes
you're a rock star i'm so impressed
right now i'm like is this a prank call
this guy is
just
crushing the game so joseph to your
question should you be contributing to
retirement the reason we're asking all
these random questions is because we're
trying to figure out if this money would
be better used to make sure that you can
cash flow the entire college experience
and get out debt free that's the only
goal you have right now at 17 years old
yes
how much money do you have
i have uh currently about uh seven uh
grand seven grand do you know how much
the entire uh four year degree is going
to cost
so uh for the first two years uh with
the community college is probably going
to run about uh 8 000 for two years
total
okay and then the remaining two years
uh i believe that's probably going to be
about uh
four thousand a year because it will
just be the major classes for the six
thousand probably okay i'd get real
clear on that number and that becomes
your a1 goal for the next few years is
cash flowing that so no i would not be
contributing to retirement right now
because we have this very near
goal ahead of us to cash flow
many thousands of dollars and so all of
your income should be going into a
savings account to make sure that we can
cover that right and a lot of times on
the front end when you're looking at
college you can kind of underestimate
the true cost there's going to be cost
of housing there's going to be expenses
as you go along along with tuition so
it's like making sure you have that pile
of cash set aside so that you don't have
any risk of going into student loan debt
is definitely going to set you up for
success yeah and okay what we've seen
joseph is you know some bright young
people like you call into the show and
what i don't want is i got 20 grand in
my 401k but i'm broke and i have to go
100 grand because i didn't think about
saving for college and i thought my
parents had a plan
and so that's what i don't want for you
as i see that happen too often where
people are going i should really start
investing at 15 years old and i love the
spirit of that and the heart behind it i
think you're going to be a
multi-millionaire
before most americans i'm not worried
about that what i am worried about is
making sure that we invest in joseph
right now and get through college debt
free get that job and once you're a game
warden now we can invest because we
don't have any huge financial goals
ahead of us except for maybe you know
upgrading in a used car maybe saving up
for a down payment things of that nature
okay
and you'll be able to save really
aggressively too it's it's holding off
on doing your 401k right now so that you
can ensure that you get a debt-free
degree and then you're going to walk out
of college with no debt really ready to
save up crushing it awesome thanks for
the call man bryson joins us up next in
billings montana bryce and welcome to
the show
hi there george and christina thanks for
having me can you hear me okay yeah it's
a little a little bit uh muffled but we
can get through it
is this any better much better what's
your question okay
um yeah so i'll try to lay a little bit
of groundwork um
rude of my question is is it the right
time for my wife and i to prepare to
maybe buy a home
um we got married last summer
and we've been
renting a little house here in town ever
since and it's been great we
um we're on baby step 3b
ish 4-ish
my wife is
graduated with her bachelor's and she's
working full-time
and
i'm working part-time and going to
school full-time to become a nurse
we
are leases
up here at the end of march
and
we've been preparing
we know that homeownership is a major
goal of ours
and we've been trying to prepare to be
ready to make that move
um
if if if it feels right but we're kind
of just not sure on the timing of it if
we've got a good enough window that we
should maybe try to buy home here or
rent in the mean until i'm done with
school
so how much money will you have by march
when your lease is up towards the down
payment
um
we we have about
the right we'd have about 70. we'd be
pretty pretty ready for a healthy 20 to
30 down payment
and you've looked at homes in in the
area and you're going all right we could
do this
yeah yeah it feels like we could
i mean whenever you're looking at homes
and
you're
a millennial looking on zillow obviously
you look at a lot of things that feel
like maybe out of reach and very fancy
and stuff but yeah and everything else
feels like well that sucks
yeah yeah well you keep talking about
how i feel about it and i want to move
from feelings to just facts on paper and
so we say is 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
with a payment that's no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay and if you
can have 20 down on top of that and
still have that payment be a quarter
then i am good with that that's how you
know you're ready and uh if you're done
leasing and you're not ready you might
need to go month-to-month for a little
while until you are ready but don't rush
into it it is the largest purchase you
will ever make in your entire life so
move slowly do it with wisdom do it with
patience and do it when you're ready
thanks so much for the call we've got
more of that coming up give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined by christina
ellis today you're listening to the
ramsay show
you guys know the housing market is hot
it has been for a while and your house
could be worth a lot more today than it
is when you bought it and that means
your old insurance policy might not give
you enough coverage anymore and what's
the point of paying for insurance that
won't swing the cost to repair or
rebuild your home
now some policies will automatically
raise your coverage to cover rising home
prices or material costs but not all of
them so if your home's value has gone up
or it's been over a year since you
checked your homeowners policy you got
to talk to one of our endorsed local
providers our elps are independent
agents who will compare multiple
policies to find the best coverage for
your home and your budget that's why
they're ramsey trusted because they'll
put you first period
go visit ramseysolutions.com
home to talk with a trusted home
insurance pro today that's ramsey
solutions dot com slash home
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five eli joins us
up next in los angeles eli welcome to
the show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
how can christina and i help
kyle yeah so um at my job i make 110k
and i've been encouraged to go back to
school to move up further up at my job
i'm just wondering if it's worth it
what do you do for a living
i'm a registered nurse at a mental
health hospital
cool
and the position i'm seeking is becoming
a psychiatrist
aha so what does that entail as far as
education
um well
for uh
my retirement age is 57 i'm currently 37
so i know becoming a psychiatrist will
probably take at most 13 years
so
just wondering if it's worth going
through it who's pressuring you to do
this who's telling you you got to go be
a psychiatrist
well i myself i find an interest in
doing it
okay so you're in this is on you because
you said it felt like there was outside
pressures which is never a good motive
to do anything
but if this is your heart's passion um
then it may be worth doing but you want
to do it a smart way where you can cash
flow the entire experience
yes
what specifically makes you want to be a
psychiatrist
um i'm just
interested in
mental and physical health
i used to be a personal trainer so i'm
like
i'm pretty fit and i used to be a yoga
instructor so i'm like
pretty
you know peaceful at mine i could
understand people
pretty well so i think i'd help being a
psychiatrist
that makes sense do you think that
there's any way that you could do that
with being an rn getting some of those
things that you really enjoy doing um
being able to do that in your career
without going back to school for 13
years
um
i
i can i could probably do that yeah
because there's a lot of overtime also
out of being a nurse so
do you have any um money saved up to go
back to school do you have any thoughts
on how you'd pay for it
getting a student loan is probably it
well we're never going to encourage you
to get a student loan that's for sure
um i mean we're all about education and
you know supporting people get
getting higher education but i do wonder
if there's a way that you can
reach some of those goals get to fulfill
that passion of working with people in
the mental health world helping them be
well with the career that you have
without going into debt if you can cash
flow it fantastic but if it involves
student loans we're definitely not going
to encourage
that you mentioned initially that you're
partially doing this because you want to
increase your income
well partially that's like a benefit of
it
but the problem is you know increasing
your income while then having a half
million dollars in student loans in the
other side you're not going to feel like
you got a raise
uh okay and so that's my worry for you
is you get out of school and you go oh
my gosh my student loans are four
thousand dollars a month and so the
extra three thousand dollars a month i'm
making feels like nothing
and you said your retirement age is 57
is that just your
when you'd like to retire
um that's the earliest i could retire at
my current job
i'm putting in 20 years of state service
what does that do for you is that a
pension thing uh
pension yes oh okay all right
well i want you to explore all the
options it sounds like you you want to
be a psychiatrist you want to help
people in a different way and there's a
lot of paths in your field i mean you
could be a nurse practitioner you could
do a lot of different things in that
realm and so i want you to really take a
good hard look at kind of a cost benefit
analysis and go all right to be a
psychiatrist it's going to take 13 years
and 500 000
or i could be an np and it would cost a
hundred thousand dollars and take three
years so start to really look at all of
your options and then figure out how
you're gonna do that with cash take that
off the table and then get creative and
go okay what can i do and when can i do
it if i'm cash flowing it
yeah i would definitely write out all
the details because i mean you may even
find 13 years sounds like a long time
for a psychology degree so make sure
that that's accurate i actually have an
associate's degree so i said 13 years
might be the max but uh it might be like
10 years since i already have an
associate i can just transfer you know
i would definitely we're all about
getting all the options on the table get
every every detail every program that
you're interested in every career path
that could be a possibility you know way
out how much does it cost and like
george said the cost benefit analysis to
see really truly what your options are
and how much they're going to cost in
total and what if you could do the you
know yoga instructor and personal
trainer you could do that as a side
hustle while staying in rn and you can
make an extra 100 000 that could help
cash flow
you know the the education you need or
you go this is this is fulfilling to me
i don't need to go be a psychiatrist now
okay so just i'm just trying to get you
to think outside of the box because
right now it feels like there's two
options stay in rn making 110 or i need
13 more years to be a psychiatrist to
make an extra 100 or 200k
so just start really
do some research talk to people who are
in those fields get a feel for what's
possible for you but no matter what you
do we want you to cash flow the
experience so that you're not sitting
here on the other end trying to pay
lenders while stepping into a new field
i understand cool well we're cheering
you on eli thanks so much for the call
uh crushing it that's awesome
amy joins us up next in chicago amy
welcome to the show
thank you thanks so much for having me
on today absolutely how can we help
i am 50 my husband is also he's recently
retired from police work and he has a
pension
so his income is basically the same as
it has always been he just picked up a
job working half time as a teacher
it's not going to be a lot of income but
i'm just wondering what we should do
with that income should i invest it in a
traditional ira or a roth
currently we have like
565 between my 403b
and his 457.
so the 457 i know we could draw from at
any time that he's retired from police
work so is it okay to
just take his whole check and put it in
a rock or at our age is that not worth
it
do you guys have any debt currently
uh
12 000 on a car and we just upgraded all
our cars so our cash is down low now
so do you not have an emergency fund
oh no we i mean i've got like 10 grand
in bank okay you got 10 grand in the
bank you owe 12 on the car any other
debt
no none house is paid everything else is
paid without college funds for the kids
we'll have to start paying on the third
kids college because we don't have
enough saves for them but i feel like
we're able to put away about five
thousand a month now
and just live on my income because uh
the house has paid off
well uh you guys are in a good spot you
got some goals ahead of you now well
number one we're going to pay off that
car asap and if that means dipping into
all the savings minus one thousand
dollars keep that in there then we're
gonna pay off that card next month
and then we're going to be about the
business of getting a three to six month
emergency fund in place
and then we can start investing but
until then we've got priorities we got
to get rid of the debt and have a solid
financial foundation because one thing
goes wrong right now and you guys don't
have the money to pay for it that's a
scary place to be
right
and then once you do that once you have
that solid emergency fund and you have
you know all the debt paid off then
start dreaming up what do you want
retirement to look like do you guys have
a vision you know for what that looks
like what kind of money you need to have
um in order to make that happen and then
sit down with the smartvestor pro and
they can walk you through how much you
need to be saving each month in order to
reach that goal absolutely you can get
in touch with one at ramseysolutions.com
and click on trusted pros there but i
love the idea of having a vision when do
we want to retire oh and by the way
we're on our 50s now there's some great
catch-up contributions we can make in
our iras so look into all your options
the smart investor pro can help with
that i want you guys to retire with
dignity with no debt sending all the
kids to college completely debt free
man how's that for retirement i love
that plan way to go amy this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm george
campbell joined today by christina ellis
and we are pumped to take your calls
about life and money the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you just need a third party to
give you some confirmation you're at a
crossroads you're not sure what to do
you think you know you got some bad
advice from your brother-in-law on get
rich quick on crypto we're here to help
you with whatever you're facing in life
triple eight eight two five five two two
five jim joins us up next in billings
montana jim welcome to the show
hello hey what's going on
well um
we retired in uh 2015 uh
and we followed the dave ramsey
uh baby steps and are totally debt free
have been since we retired
and i was just wondering at this point
in time
uh it would it be better to
try and invest anymore or just
live off of our
uh retirement funds and our pensions or
what should we be doing now how much do
you guys have in retirement
uh about six hundred thousand
okay and what about the pension
uh the pensions are about six thousand a
year i mean a month okay 6 000 a month
is that enough to live off of the
pension alone without touching the
retirement accounts
yeah we haven't touched anything since
2015.
nice and you've had a great retirement
so far
yeah we do everything we want to do and
we
you know we
donate
at least 20 percent to
charities and
we do everything we want and we've got
emergency funds and everything in place
wow and you still have margin left over
after that and you're going what do we
do with this money
yeah
that's a good problem to have yeah is
your house paid
yes that is fantastic i mean this is the
dream jim people are listening in going
how do i be gym when i grow up
this is awesome so to answer your
question should you continue investing
yeah investing is a great thing to do
even in retirement do you have kids
uh yeah we've got two
adult children great well how old you
said you guys are how old
uh we're both 73 73.
okay well let's say you know you can go
another 20 years this pension for life
what's the details of this and is there
a survivor piece to the equation with
the pension
uh on mine yes there is uh i'm retired
military so
i i set it up that
about
50 or 60 percent will still go to my
wife if i pass away great i just want to
make sure that she's taken care of and
you have 600 000 which is it's not
nothing and as that money continues to
grow if you don't touch it you know
you're gonna see at you know let's say
nine or ten percent growth that's some
serious growth over the next 10 20 years
right especially if you're not touched
yeah all we touch is uh the
required
minimum distribution that's all we take
the rmds okay that's awesome are you
working with a financial advisor
yes okay and do you like them
they've been treating you well you feel
like we're teaching you
yeah we got him
early on uh
he was an eop and uh he's moved on from
that sense but we really liked him and
he's always done good for us so great
i want to make sure you have someone in
your corner who's looking out for you
and doing the the crunching all the
numbers going hey here's what this money
looks like for the next you know 20
years but absolutely if you've got money
left over and you're living the best
life you can live
having amazing experiences and you're
not you know pinching pennies in
retirement then i think it's wise to
continue to invest and they can help
walk you through what those options are
at your age how much is your housework
about 400 000. that's amazing so you
guys are officially baby steps
millionaires you followed the plan and
you're
living the life yeah well yeah one day
we're a millionaire and the next day
we're down to 950 000. so i never called
in for the millionaire show because i
never know exactly where i am but it
depends on what the stock market's doing
right yeah
well with that pension that changes
everything for you guys so that's
awesome that you have that extra income
and thank you so much for your service
jim
yeah we uh our pitches are about
well
everything it rolled into one is a
little over 80 000 a year so
that's not bad
that is awesome i love that you guys are
living out that so that you know we have
so many people calling in talking about
you know the struggles of having debt
and trying to save right now and they're
a lot younger in their journey and you
guys are setting the example of what
that so that looks like you're able to
give generously you're able to live and
do all the things that you want in
retirement so really good job you can
hear the levity in his voice he's just
like i got some extra money what do i do
with it life's good thanks so much for
the college i appreciate it
jan joins us up next in kansas city jan
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much how can we help today
well
my husband and i are both
still working we're in our late 50s
we got married late in life
we weren't good at saving before then
but right now we are within
arm's reach of paying off our house
otherwise we're debt-free
we actually have enough in
savings to go ahead and just write that
check and pay it off
but my husband is looking to um need a
new car he's got a 275
000 miles on his car
and um so we're kind of trying to decide
do we just keep plugging money away
to eventually get him a car when his
finally you know kicks the bucket or um
should we go ahead and take bite the
bullet pass the house and then you know
hit real hard put all that money that we
were putting in the mortgage into
um saving for a car
yeah what's your income household
uh together about 110 okay
and how much is left on the mortgage
uh
25 000. love it and how much do you have
total in cash and savings
uh 26 000. oh and how much is that of
that is your emergency fund
all of it uh okay well
uh it doesn't look like we're doing
either of them right now but you're so
close you're gonna be there my guess is
about 15 or 20 of that is gonna be a
three to six month emergency fund for
you guys
right okay
so let's say we have an extra let's call
it 20 grand is the emergency fund so
right now you have 6 000 of you know
money you can do whatever you want with
you can throw it at the house you can
put it towards the car
and personally what i did was i waited i
had a crappy car and i waited to upgrade
it until i paid off the house and that's
just me personally i need kind of the
carrot dangling in front of me to keep
me motivated for my goal and that might
be the same for you guys based on your
personality
right what do you think you know your
husband
yeah i mean he would like a different
car doesn't have any ac in it um oh boy
in the kansas city summer
yeah and how much is it to fix it
uh quite a bit
quite a bit um you know he's had he's
had to
dump quite a bit of money into it but
it's cheaper than a car so um and the
dashboard sometimes cut doesn't work so
that's kind of dangerous that's
comforting so okay
yeah
yeah well there may be looking at a stop
gap solution where we go all right we're
going to get a car it's going to be
better than one we have but we're gonna
spend
six to seven grand to get him a a
different car right now a used car
then we're gonna attack the house and
then once we have the house we're gonna
start saving up to get him a better car
that's what i would do if i was in your
shoes christina can uh she may have a
different take no i think that sounds
great that's what i was thinking i do
wonder um about how long do you think
it'll take you all to pay off the
mortgage if you do that strategy and you
buy the car five six thousand dollars
with the cash you have that much longer
are you looking at to pay off that
mortgage
um
well right now we're trying to do double
payments um
and so we're looking at maybe two or
three years
three years to pay off 25 grand i feel
like you guys can do better than that
okay
that's my challenge what a year making
110 with with no payments except for the
house you know or
you could do this
well we've been slamming stuff into you
know savings every month too for the
emergency fund so that's our car fund so
that's kind of where we've been
so we should put more towards the house
is what you're saying that's what i
would do i mean i'd get him something
for now that sounds like miserable just
driving around that thing you guys are
working too hard to be driving that
thing around so upgrade that attack the
house and there's always another car out
there we can get later on but do it with
cash don't go into debt call us back
when you're debt-free we love to hear it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by
best-selling author and ramsay
personality christina ellis and we are
taking your calls about life and money
right here on the ramsay show triple
eight
five 825-5225 joins us up next in
raleigh north carolina tony welcome to
the show
oh hey george hey christina how are you
we're doing great what's going on with
you yeah
um just um
question um i know i
had kind of sold my vehicle about a year
year or so ago um to kind of fast track
um becoming debt-free which i am now
nice i know my
uh my sister actually had a car that was
kind of just sitting uh at my parents
house on her old car so i kind of fixed
it up put about two thousand bucks into
it
and uh kind of have you know driven that
um since last last year sometime
beginning of last year and i think
it was kind of for my niece she's going
to be graduating on the high school soon
so i know knew her parents weren't going
to have the money to fix it up so it was
kind of a win-win for both of us
but i know she's going to be getting her
license
pretty soon and i knew this ahead of
time but i did become debt-free um i
don't want to go back into getting
another um auto loan i'm scared that
might affect me and
uh you know saving towards my emergency
fund um or also you know home buying
later down the road so i just want to
know what my um exactly what my options
were now well your options are to buy a
car with cash and that means we're going
to buy a car with cash and save up and
buy a car with cash
it's that simple so what kind of car
would you be looking at
um i know in my research i definitely
know now i want a toyota or honda just a
basic you know sedan corolla civic good
man you know something used old okay
so have you looked at your area in
raleigh and said hey what is a you know
what's a 2012 civic gonna cost
yeah i have um you know i just know now
with my you know my emergency fund um at
about uh at about four or five thousand
now in that in that emergency fund um
and i know she's gonna be
you know her parents don't live here um
they actually live in greensboro so i
know that i'm gonna have to be giving
her that you know that car back soon so
that's where the the worry came in we
got to get the emergency fund beefed up
but also get you a car asap yeah
how soon do you have to give it back
um i would say within the next
i would say maybe five six months or so
okay and you got the car for free but
you put two grand of repairs into it
yeah yeah
okay yeah
so if we got a few months how what's
your income
about 50 52 000 a year okay what do you
do for a living
um in an operations airport cool
well
how quickly could you get a ten thousand
dollar emergency fund and then save up
another six or seven to get a car so
we're talking another 15 000 saved
within
four months
yeah
what would that take could you take some
side jobs some side hustles
yeah i could work overtime i don't know
what your situation is at work
yeah i could work with you i can work
some overtime um definitely you know
have a few jobs here or there
um just to make up the income yeah and
this is for a short season i'm not
talking two years of this i'm saying for
four months can we basically double our
income in order to be in a real good
spot when we have to hand over this car
and i would get really clear on the
timeline of this like you're saying
maybe five to six months but obviously
if we're trying to save super
aggressively and get to that goal of a
car a month or two is going to make a
huge difference so i would have that
conversation as soon as possible just to
figure that out so then you can map out
you know what do i need to save each
month how many extra jobs do i need to
get what does this journey actually look
like and you also may want to adjust the
type of car you get like if you're if
they're like hey we need this car in two
to three months i mean maybe you're
looking at a 5 000 car for right now and
then you can save up and get something
better in the future yeah it's a great
point there and if you could just say
hey listen i'm gonna have this money by
march does that work for you guys can i
give her the car then
and if they're a little bit flexible or
she can borrow a car for now and give
you a little more time that's gonna
really help your situation
okay are they pretty flexible sounds
good
yes they are um yeah i guess i just kind
of got caught up in the
uh i guess further
i guess further down the road you know
where we are now and
you know just rent prices and things
like that i kind of start to get a
little worried
um you know that that would kind of
affect the budget you know in terms of
if i were to get another car or if
they're not you know flexible if i do
have to give it back
um so i was just kind of a little
nervous just a little nervous about that
well have no fear we're going to create
a sinking fund line item in your budget
that is for that new car and we might
put that in a separate savings account
versus your emergency fund because it
can get all squirrely when you're just
looking at one savings account going
well i have enough for a car but i don't
know if i have my emergency fund now so
i would separate the two and get set up
a new savings account just for the car
and that way you know exactly where you
stand at all times
sounds perfect but your a1 is getting
that emergency fund beefed up to three
to six months of expenses do you know
your monthly expenses right now
um yeah we're at about i would say about
20 about 2500. 2500. okay
so four months would be 10 card i would
say maybe about 1700 i'm sorry
oh okay so we're talking about 10 grand
or so would be a fully funded emergency
fund and you're you're close to that
and so within a few months you'll be
there and then the next few months
you're going to be focused on saving up
for that car and whenever you have to
give it back whatever car we can get for
that amount of money that's what we do
and it may be it may mean getting
scrappy and we're going to facebook
marketplace and craigslist and
negotiating and doing it with a you know
cashiers check and trying to get a deal
but that's going to be your best bet
sounds good well it's obvious to you
that you're willing to drive a car that
you fixed up and that that's what you've
been driving recently so i think if you
just kind of keep that mindset of like
i'm not really going for it no one's
going to be impressed with this car and
that's okay we're running our own race
and tony's good with that appreciate the
call man
james is up next in columbus ohio james
what's up
hey george and christina how you guys
doing so great what's going on with you
i'm good so
i had a question um i'm currently in
college and i'm going into my junior
year
and um my question uh so i guess to give
you a little bit of back story first um
so my first year for college i actually
ended up taking about out about three
thousand dollars in student loans um
and i've been you know working really
hard to try to make sure i don't have to
do that anymore
so over the summers i've been working
different internships and uh you know
trying to save some money that way
um but i've also been working during the
school year as well um so
during the school years i have a part
i guess sort of like a part-time job um
working as like a laboratory assistant
and
here recently i just got offered um you
know two different
i guess you know job offers uh to work
part-time
um for two different companies
uh outside of the school so um and i
guess my my dollar with that
is um so working as a laboratory
assistant it's been really good because
you know it's sort of more flexible with
my my school schedule
so i i feel more comfortable you know
being able to get my schoolwork done
and and also you know them sort of
understanding you know how my schedule
is and working with that
um
with these two job offers that i i got
i'd be you know working outside of the
school
and um
do they understand you're a student will
they be flexible with your schedule
um so i think they do i had a
conversation with both of them i think
they they do understand
um the the thing though there is that um
with those two job offers those would be
more so in my you know career field uh i
should clarify my architecture major
cool so um working
uh with those you know one of those two
companies that you know just had the
chance to talk to um
they would one you know help me get
experience but to also um
allow me to collect hours towards
my exam that i would have to take um to
become a registered architect is it also
a bump in pay
that again is it also a bump in pay
um so pain is about even across the
board
um yeah i'd say that all the positions
would be relatively even playing field
as far as pay goes
okay have you gone down that path then
yeah that's great i mean it's in your
career field uh just you got to be in
communication with them and say this is
what this looks like for me to take this
part-time job are you good with that and
have that in writing and then move
forward with it man that's awesome get
clarity because i think this could be a
great opportunity to make sure you
completely understand the hours the
opportunity and what's involved as ken
coleman says clarity breeds confidence
there you go ken coleman quote to end
this hour thanks to christina ellis all
the folks in the booth and to you
america thanks for listening we'll be
back with you before you know
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print entree leadership
podcast joined today by my fellow ramsay
personality christina ellis and we are
taking your money calls this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call don't be shy we
don't bite dave's not here it's gonna be
a very pleasant kind show okay no one's
gonna get yelled at unless you rile me
up which is very much possible
daniel kicks us off in tampa daniel
welcome to the show
hey there thank you for taking the call
and i appreciate it george and christina
thank you for all you do
great so uh my wife and i are currently
in step two now we kind of discovered
the whole baby steps a little later in
life we already had some retirements set
aside um
but here's the question um comparables
in the area are running for about 660
for our house um we currently owe 325.
um we do have a growing tent well we
have you know a family i think we're
outgrowing the size of our home so
ideally we'd like to be in a
five-bedroom home or so so those are
running for about 8.50 in the area wow
um
so so here's my question we we bought
the home just before the spike so we owe
about 325 on it currently we have a good
amount of equity if we're able to to
sell that and of course that'll kick
start us from step two straight on to
you know the next i believe step four at
that point
my question is is that a is that a good
approach should we sell our current home
use the equity to buy a bigger home and
get us out of
you know the existing step two
it can be now when you say buy a bigger
home it means we're going possibly
further into debt so it's not
necessarily a the best move right but i
do love i mean people make sacrifices
all the time to get out of debt and one
of those things is we're willing to sell
the home take the equity pay off the
debt and whatever's left we then move on
and go all right what can we afford now
so what's the home worth if you sold
today
it would be about 650
650 and you owe 325.
how big is your family you said you
needed to
upgrade get a little more space yeah so
we my eyes and i both work from home we
have three kids it's a three to three
two currently
um so it's a little tight okay what's
your income
it's 140 combined
and how much debt do you have
um so we've got a van
about 20k on the van and i think i'm not
mistaken another 12 or so on credit
cards
and that's all the debt except for that
325 mortgage
correct that's it and we do have some
retirement i would say combined probably
close to the 100 000 range
okay are you guys currently investing
yes okay
well you may not like my advice but it
is to pause investing while we pay off
the debt now if you're selling the house
tomorrow and this is all going down you
may not have to do that but uh following
the ramsay plan it's counter cultural
it's weird and we focus on one thing at
a time so that we actually make some
progress and looking at the numbers here
it doesn't give me a lot of confidence
because if you sold for you know you
said 650 you may net
less than 300 then we still have to pay
off 30 grand of debt leaving us with
about 270. you tracking
so 270 down on an 850 000 home you're
talking almost 600 000 in mortgage which
is going to double your mortgage payment
which doesn't put you guys in a great
spot financially even though you're
debt-free
sure and so
i think we need to pause or we go to a
maybe a lateral house that has more room
that maybe a little further out you know
you may have to make some compromises
here and kind of reset the expectations
of what home is next
sure sure and for what it's worth in the
event that we do sell today and say we
we sit on i know there's a gap of six
months or so we do have a place to live
you know my folks were kind enough to
extend an invitation to house our family
until we do find that bigger home so
we're sort of counting on that but
that's probably a six month margin
but even then you're not going to get
you're still going to have over a half
million dollar mortgage
right
yeah and i love i love that you have the
desire to pay off the baby step to debt
i love that you want to get rid of that
van i love that you want to get rid of
the credit card and if you are selling
your current house to downgrade and
create more margin where you could pay
off that debt and then not increase debt
in another area i'd be all for it but i
think just that makes me nervous going
up so much in-house and like george said
having such a big mortgage following
that that's just kind of like a little
bit nerve-wracking i think especially
with having three kids um it just feels
a little bit nerve-wracking if i were in
your shoes what's your take-home pay
every month
one day
is that 60 1600 okay
because i'm looking at the numbers here
and uh if you did a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage which is the only mortgage i'm
gonna tell you to get and you put 270
down on an 850 000 house in this market
your
monthly payment is 5500
you guys won't be able to eat
ouch yeah and so even six months of
saving even while living with the
parents it's not going to change the
numbers drastically enough to make this
a wise financial move so what that tells
me is this you make 140 you've got 30 in
debt we can pay off the debt and stay in
the home for now and you said you feel
like we're running out of space we might
have to get a little bit creative right
now and see if we can squeeze out
another year
living here until we make a move and
again it may be a more of a lateral move
we may only get a four bedroom instead
of a five and we make that work
how many kids do you have
three
okay can either share a bedroom
they currently do okay true
are they miserable
do they feel like they're in a prison
no we are no you are it's the parents of
course
yeah another
they're great
well you guys are you're on the right
path what's the van worth
and
uh well i know that we owe 20 i i
haven't done numbers as far as what it's
worth i do have a paid off vehicle
that's about
just about the same it's it's definitely
worth about the same okay and you need
the two cars right you got to haul the
kids around is that what the vans for
yeah just you know in the event that one
breaks down we do have the backup means
of transportation but you only need one
car
i would say we do just need one because
you know
we do both work from home
okay
well i'm just wondering if the van's
worth you know 30 and we and you owe 20
on it that gives you a net of 10 and you
almost clean up the credit card debt and
we're debt free by tomorrow and then we
can start stacking up cash uh to make
this home move
that's an option now you may need the
van or you you know but i'm just looking
at the options here going if you don't
only need one car you both work from
home the kids can fit in the other car
for now if one breaks down you have an
emergency fund right
you're right
so we're good we'll go fix it up we'll
go get another car whatever we have to
do to get back on the road but that's
one way to clean this mess up now i
don't know the worth of the vehicle so
that's your homework assignment is to
look into that and figure out is this
worth selling there's no need to it's
not a huge part of your financial world
but if you're itching to get out of debt
fast i would do that way before i would
think about selling the house
way less of a hassle
okay so that's the move man i'm pulling
for you that's tough three kids you got
some debt we want to upgrade the house
but it's gonna have to wait and the kids
they won't remember it they're just
gonna remember the awesome childhood
they had sharing a bedroom right yeah
and you'll get there this is only for a
season you will get there you'll get
that bigger house have a little space
and room to breathe we're gonna do it
the right way and move at the speed of
cash pay off the debt and do it with
wisdom thanks for the call man this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
how many times have you found yourself
saying one day when thinking about a
goal that you have
one day i'll be able to buy a house one
day i'll be happy with my career or one
day i won't have to battle with anxiety
anymore well stop waiting around
whatever your one day is you gotta start
now and that is why we created smart
conference it's the one day event where
we tackle all areas of your life and
guys let's face it we could all use that
kind of boost right now you're gonna
hear from the nation's top thought
leaders on money career mental health
relationships marriage and leadership
this event is hitting the road and will
be coming to dallas texas on saturday
october 22nd but event passes are
selling fast to the vip vip and platinum
passes already gone sold out but you can
still get general access passes for just
39 bucks for an all-day event
best-selling authors and world-class
speakers rachel cruz dr john deloney ken
coleman myself christina ellis and dave
ramsey will be there in full force not
to mention we've got some special guests
our friends and leadership experts from
life church craig and amy grochelle will
be there and of course we've got some
big surprises planned too some amazing
live entertainment some music maybe some
of the personalities will be a part of
that we don't know christina maybe
christina will sing
i've heard from your husband who's out
there in the lobby that you've got some
pipes gosh that's time don't hide it
under a bushel christina
let it shine
it's my first ramsay live event i am oh
my gosh oh that's wild well i'm pumped
to hear you speak there you can go to
ramseysolutions.com
events to get your event passes today
you don't want to miss this people
travel from all over the country to be
at this event and we love seeing you
guys out there we're going to pack out
an entire arena how's that for your
first speaking event here at ramsay
amazing just in a giant arena with like
8 000 of your best friends no pressure
no pressure it's gonna be so great it's
a blast ramsay solutions.com
events we'll see you in dallas texas in
october cannot wait open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's talk about your life
and your money tim has decided to do
that he's out there in tucson arizona
tim welcome to the show
hey thank you for having me i appreciate
you guys absolutely what's going on
so um
my wife just graduated from nursing
school so we're moving into i guess a
season where we're going to be making
more money than we've ever done
before it
so
um i guess
our first goal is we're going to pay off
debt we have roughly 20 000 in debt
between a credit card and a car payment
um but from there i just
me and my wife aren't quite on the same
page as far as what to do you know i i
just don't want to make mistakes and i
want to i guess take her along this
journey because i've been listening to
you guys for a little while but she
doesn't want to
what does she do
well i i
she uh you know obviously wants to get a
new car and
you know kind of
you know enjoy some of the money which
i'm perfectly fine with but i also want
to set up our kids to be able to go to
college and you know have have have
money saved for retirement not just
spend all of our money you know as it
comes in and just going straight out you
know yeah
where do you think her resistance is
coming from because it sounds like
there's kind of like a hard line where
she's just like nat don't want to hear
it
well it's definitely you know she both
of us grew up not really having money i
mean just the fact i mean
what we make now is more than you know
any of us had grown up so i think i
don't know it doesn't want to deprive
the kids from having you know going on
trips and doing stuff
so i think i think it's the you know
scarcity of money is kind of what has
driven it
how have you talked to her about it so
far whenever you've told her about this
plan and you're excited about it what
have your conversations look like
um
like it's it's you know just kind of
spelling out what what i would like to
have done
and then she's like yeah but i want to
do this and
i it's it's very you know money isn't
something that was talked about growing
up for her or me
and so it's new i guess
well one of the ways to get on the same
page is to have
common shared language and i think
that's one of the reasons financial
peace university has been so powerful in
getting couples on the same page and
improving marriages and so i'm gonna
give that to you guys for free if you
agree to watch all nine lessons and go
through it together
absolutely that's one of those things
where now she's like oh you just
explained it terribly this dave guy is
way better at this and you go yeah
exactly
because what it sounds like a lot of the
time is well dave said and we have to
sacrifice and we're never going to eat
out and we can't have anything nice and
she's like what dude i worked so hard to
get through nursing school and now
you're telling me i can't enjoy life
you know what i mean like you get how
that sounds
no absolutely and i don't want to sound
cheap or any i mean that's not the i
mean it's just i don't i don't want to i
don't want to do stupid you know and and
i think that's what you tell her you say
hey listen
i've made a lot of stupid decisions i
haven't done a great job leading our
family well in the area finances and i
want to improve in that area and one of
the ways i want to do that is go through
financial peace university we got it for
free because this guy george and this
girl christina they were very nice and
they said we have to go through it
and if she does that i think that's
going to change the way she sees this
when you go wow this guy's got a vision
for our future and i'm in it i'm a part
of it and it includes going on vacation
and upgrading cars and enjoying life but
it comes at a time
once we're debt-free with a fully funded
emergency fund and i'm sure she's
goal-oriented you gotta be to be in her
field right
absolutely and so you set the goal and
say all right honey it's gonna take us
two years to become debt-free she's
gonna go what that's forever you go yeah
that sucks what if we could do it in a
year what would it take what could we
sacrifice and then she gets excited
about it because now it's competitive
right well i think it's especially
important to avoid that scarcity
language like you said you guys both
grew up without a lot of money she
probably heard a lot of that growing up
so if she hears you come in and say
we're just going to sacrifice and we're
going to pay off this debt then she's
like immediately tensing up and going oh
no thank you but if you can cast that
vision of like this program will help us
build wealth it will help us not ever
have to worry about money in the future
yes we may need to sacrifice for a
period of time but it's so that someday
we can just live and give so generously
like
change that language so that it's just
she doesn't have that instant reflex of
oh gosh no yeah it's hard i mean it's a
lot of new stuff that she's going to be
going what and then over time when she
starts to get on board gets on a budget
starts baby step one and two she's gonna
get excited about this that's what
always happens so what's your new found
income
so
uh we will be roughly 200 000 so up from
we i was just making 75.
i just gotta increase to about 105 and
then she's going to be making anywhere
from 80 to 100. we love it that's
amazing so making two hundred thousand
you go how quickly could we pay off 20.
i mean we're thinking yeah december
we'll have it paid off um you know just
you can do better than that rough quick
math
yeah where's all the money going are you
guys investing currently
no
no um we i mean we do have three kids
and we've had that's where all the
money's going there it is
we found out like i said this is this
she hasn't even started yet so i she
won't we won't be seeing her first
paycheck probably until
middle of the month or so got it
so
well this is a good place this is a
fresh start and i think you you pitch
that and go hey listen with this new
income it's going to put us in a
completely different place financially
and i want to make sure that we are very
wise with this
and that includes having fun and
spending uh but you know part of the
plan is there's only three things you
can do with money give save and spend
and i think all she's hearing now is the
save part and she's going but i want to
enjoy this i've worked so hard for this
we've never had this kind of money i've
always grew up you know worrying about
where the next paycheck is going to come
from
so i think once you see it that way you
give a little
a little open-handed there you save a
little which makes you feel good about
the future and protects you from murphy
and emergencies and everything that
happens in life and then the spending
part which i think that's the part she's
most excited about right now
for sure
and if she gets the car we got to get
her an a used car now it could be a
nicer used car you guys make 200 grand
but we're doing it once we're completely
out of debt and once we have a fully
funded emergency fund then we can
upgrade the car then we can go on
vacations there's a time and place for
it and it's baby step four and she's
gonna learn all about that in financial
peace university so hang on the line
our friend austin's gonna pick up he
will make sure we get that over to you
we're also gonna throw in every dollar
premium which is our budgeting tool that
will help you guys get on a plan and i
want you to work on the budget together
i don't want you to go in a room and go
honey here's the budget and she goes huh
what no i don't want to do your plan
make it her plan she's got to have a say
in the budget line items and that will
get you guys on the same page if not
have her call in and talk to christina
christina will persuade her you probably
want some persuasive speeches in your
day were you in debate club i was not in
the bank club but i did do speeches and
i'm just scared to debate you that's all
very intimidating i will pump her up
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five
five this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
my co-host today is christina ellis i'm
george campbell this is the ramsay show
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
they're their number one online retailer
of custom window covering you get free
samples free shipping with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal
today's question comes from colin in
washington i'm 18 years old and have
approximately 20 000 in cash 1 000
invested and 7 000 in my roth ira i am
debt free and have a car worth around 12
000. i will be moving across the country
to attend college and selling my car
since i won't need it while i'm there
my education expenses will be entirely
covered including housing and food which
means i will have over thirty thousand
dollars cash sitting in my savings
account wow good job
what what plan should i have for this
money while i'm in college that's
wow i feel like there's a trend
happening with
wise young people out there where
they're doing better than their parents
are and they've got a pile of cash and
no debt and so my goal is to stay that
way for colin and if he sells this car
like he's saying he has 20 cash right
now he sells the car for 12. he's got 32
000 sitting there he's wondering what
plan he should have for this i'm gonna
read into it and guess that colin is
asking
should i and can i invest this money
because this guy loves to see his money
work for him which is incredible at 18
years old to have that mindset that
desire to grow your wealth and to
actually save money that is amazing and
to actually have college completely pay
for i wish we were talking to him
because i have so many questions yeah
when he says my education expenses will
be entirely covered including housing
and food we don't know where that's
being covered from and if that's in you
know is this a blood oath that this is
going to happen for the next four years
or is there an off chance that something
could fall through or there's expenses
that he's not thinking about that he
might need to cover right so i'm worried
about him throwing all this money into
the market for the next four years while
he's in school i would much rather have
him put this money in a high yield
savings account while he's there oh
we're gonna go the boring safe route so
people hate it but the good news is the
interest rates have been rising mine's
sitting at about two percent right now
which you know it's back to how it was
in about 2019 that's where the interest
rates were on savings accounts and so i
feel pretty good about that yeah that's
awesome and i think that that's just
great advice because you are 18 you're
going into college and i love that you
have tuition paid for i love that you
have housing paid for but there might be
some surprises you know you may get to
that college and hate it and go i really
want to transfer schools or perhaps i
mean
obviously we hope this doesn't happen
but maybe you know something happens
with your scholarship and you don't get
the same amount the second year or maybe
you need a car you didn't think you
needed a car but you find this amazing
job off campus and you actually got to
drive there
having that money gives you a safety net
to be able to have options you're not
locked into you know one certain thing
if you have that cash plus you may want
to go to grad school and we want that to
be debt free as well so having that
money saved up while you're in college
is just the safest best route yeah and
he's 18. so he's got plenty of time to
invest and become a multi-millionaire
and become one of our baby steps
millionaires and he's already got some
money invested now he said he has 7k in
the roth ira he said he has 1k invested
i don't know where that 1k i mean that
could be crypto uh for all we know but
it sounds like he's got a good head on
his shoulders he's got a pile of cash at
18. that would give me some great
financial peace while i'm in school that
i can cover anything that comes up and
once i'm out of school i'm ready to roll
with a pile of cash and that's if he
does not work at all in school and
doesn't add to that pile of cash right
that's i was thinking i'm like don't
don't stop here keep going like whatever
you're doing to make this money and to
build this wealth so early on is just
awesome i hope that you'll leave with a
down payment for a house or something
really incredible so that's your plan
colin is to keep that cash nice and safe
in a high-yield savings account and be
ready for the future cash flow your
entire college experience graduate
debt-free then you can get a sweet ride
and you're gonna do it with cash and
you'll have a sweet down payment
potentially if you keep this route up
and he's gonna be calling us at 22 going
i got a house
right and at 30
saying you know i'm a baby steps paid
off i'm a millionaire we love to see it
let's keep that trend going
all right let's go to the phones the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five sam joins us up
next in st louis sam welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely how are you doing how can we
help
um i'm okay um i have a question on a
little bit of an emotional level so i'm
sorry about my voice oh it's okay take
your time
i'm 31 years old i'm a single mom
um
my daughter and myself still live with
my parents
and it's
it's great it's fine
but
where i am now i need to make a change
um i
have my own space that's fine but i
would love
to have my own
house or property um
my grandpa
has been sick he
since march he's had maybe
two to four mini strokes
um
he's in the hospital now waiting on
surgery
and it's been delayed for many reasons
my one option
was to move in with
my grandma and grandpa
to
be a safety net for them
if something else were to happen
um
and
my grandmother and i uh worked out some
she's a very old-school
[Music]
so we sat down like formally and
financially and she's like okay well
you're not just gonna be here you this
is these are the rules
uh grandma's got boundaries
grandma's got boundaries
yes
you will come to church with us
and that's fine but we worked out a
budget as far as rent and utilities and
input and that would be
rounding up about 750
my other question is
is i currently pay no rent here where
i'm at i i pay the water bill and i help
with groceries and buy supplies for the
house and that probably comes about to
i would say three to three hundred fifty
dollars a month depending on the time of
year okay so your expenses are about to
increase by 400 if you move
correct yes
and my other question is or should i
just stay where i'm at
two options i know i want to save for my
own
land acreage
crappy house what what have you but my
question is should i stay here
obviously with less or should i move
there with less
because what i'm hoping to work towards
is buying a plot of land
about
eight and a half acres and it's priced
at 64 000 currently
and then you build
on yes it does have the it is
grandfathered in to build on
um i think it is a very wooded area and
most people use it for um
camping
okay or like a conservation
type of
zoning i would guess you would call it
okay um how much debt do you have sam
i have
around about 9 800
and what kind of debt is that
um
15
1600 is from a personal loan
i have a combined
credit card debt of 7200
and a store card with just over a
thousand okay
and what's your income
my income varies i'm a waitress and
i work part-time because i also
homeschool my child
so
the take-home pay on a weekly basis
is anywhere from 400 to 900.
okay i believe what i filed last year
was
between 17 and 18 000
but i hope to pass over 20 000 this year
and are you safe at your parents house
is it an okay situation yes yes yes it's
just emotional yeah well i'm gonna stay
there for a beat i think you need to
increase your income we've got to get
rid of this debt we've got to get an
emergency fund in place then we can look
at moving in with grandma uh but right
now you can't swing the extra 400 bucks
that's an entire paycheck and you're
trying to take care of this little one
and you're trying to buy a house that
will come later right now we've got to
get rid of the debt have an emergency
fund in place and i'm going to gift you
financial peace university i hope that
gives you some confidence and what to do
next and hang on the line austin will
pick up we're going to include every
dollar premium to help you get on a plan
for every dollar you have coming in from
this job and possibly a new job as you
try to increase your income and increase
that shovel thanks for the call
[Music]
[Music]
so
i'm george campbell host of the fine
print and the entree leadership podcast
you can find both of those on the ramsay
network or wherever you find your
podcast joined today by christina ellis
best-selling author scholarship expert
famously known for going to school
debt-free getting half a million dollars
in scholarships
do you still remember those days like it
was yesterday maybe not yesterday i feel
like i'm getting older i have a birthday
this week
well all the kids will do that to you
too you got some real cute babies yeah
having a one in three-year-old kind of
makes you feel like you're up there a
bit but yes i do remember getting the
scholarships and getting that letter in
the mail snail mail back then um
i'm opening it up and just seeing like
wow this is literally thousands and
thousands of dollars which is what i get
so excited to talk about with kids just
being like this application that you can
fill out in one hour can equal literally
ten thousand dollars like where else can
you make that kind of money i mean
that's that's the og get rich quick
right there
you know forget crypto kids go apply for
some scholarships there you go good bang
for your buck there well i love that
you're inspiring the next generation to
uh the preventative medicine if you will
to avoid student loans and show them
that it can be done you can cash flow it
there's a dozen ways to do this it's not
always scholarships or grants sometimes
it means work sometimes it means mom and
dad we're able to save but it starts
with having an honest conversation which
most parents are not doing because they
have their own shame and guilt and
baggage and they're not great with money
and so they're like i don't want to have
this awkward conversation with junior
about how we're broke
well that's the thing that i hear so
often when people hear my story they
often say to me hey like why did no one
sit me down in high school and say
i could win scholarships there are other
ways to go to school other than taking
on student loan debt and they're just
frustrated so it's like parents
mentors anyone who has a relationship
with a teenager who's thinking about
going to college have these
conversations like you have the
opportunity to be that person that they
look back on and go wow somebody did sit
me down and talk about this like they
don't have to be that person that's 25
years old with a hundred thousand
dollars in debt asking why did no one
talk to me about this you can be that
person i know i wish i had more honest
conversations with my family i just
thought they were like loaded and had it
taken care of and it turns out it was
like we'll take care of it with student
loans
and then next thing you know i graduate
with 36 000 in student loan debt and it
was monopoly money to me at you know 17
18 years old i had no idea what scale
that would be and how much money i would
be making because in your mind as a kid
you're like well i'll make 100 grand out
of college right great and i remember
interviewing some kids for our high
school curriculum we did a segment and i
thought i was just going to ask them hey
like what are you going to do with your
future what do you think college is
going to be how much is going to cost
and it turned out to be an accidental
interrogation there was legitimately
some kids that ran out of there crying
oh my george because
i was asking benign innocuous questions
but what i didn't realize was that no
one had ever talked to them about this
stuff and so they left feeling scared
and insecure going i don't know now that
they're feeling certainly feel the
weight of what this could mean for their
future and how what they thought in
their mind may not be reality and that's
what's happening there's a disconnect
between reality and the decisions we're
making at 17 18 when it comes to college
and going well i want to go out of state
because i want to get away from home but
the out-of-state school is you know 20
grand more a year and now we're 80 grand
extra in the hole and mom and dad didn't
have the conversation they're not saving
because they're also broke keeping up
with the joneses and now junior's
graduating with a hundred grand in debt
and no job is ever going to be enough
and so now he can't do what he wants to
do
because of this debt in his life and we
saw that with a borrowed future
documentary featuring some heartbreaking
stories you were featured in there as a
success story trying to be on the other
side going it doesn't have to be this
way right one of the key parts of my
story is that my mom actually sat me
down freshman year and she said
christina i can't afford to pay for your
college education so you need to figure
out how you're going to pay for college
and some people might think wow that was
kind of harsh like why were why were you
telling a freshman this but at the same
time i look back and i just feel like
that was a gift because she really
couldn't afford to pay for my education
and if she wouldn't have told me that
early on and let me in on the financial
reality we were facing i wouldn't have
gone through the effort of applying for
scholarships and having the opportunity
to go debt-free so be willing to have
hard conversations i know there's there
like you said there can be a lot of
shame around money a lot of guilt a lot
of like oh man i wish we had this saved
for your college education but we don't
but take that and pour it into a
proactive decision to go you know we
don't have it saved but guess what there
are all sorts of ways you can graduate
debt-free you know there's scholarships
there's going to
a tuition-free school there's community
college first there's um getting a job
potentially that will help pay for your
tuition there are so many options out
there so have the conversation yes yeah
most people back themselves into a
corner and go there's two options either
i go to my dream school with a pile of
student loan debt or i'm a failure
forever and i hate life and you got to
realize there's a lot more options than
that and school school at the end of the
day
it's a degree and yes we want you to
have a great experience there's a lot of
growth and maturity that hopefully
happens in in college and not a lot of
bad decisions but remember why you're
there we're not just paying a big bill
to have a good time right that's not
what college is about and just don't get
lost in the idea that you have to go to
the most expensive fancy school like you
said they
often see those two options i gotta go
to this dream school that takes a ton of
debt or i'm a failure and that's just
not true especially working at a really
competitive workplace here like ramsey
we see people who come from all sorts of
backgrounds we have people you know who
went to community college and then
transferred to a four-year school
sitting next to people who went to a
super competitive expensive university
and they're doing the same job that's
right and so it's like it's not just the
name on your degree the title you know
be willing to explore different options
that allow you to go debt-free that's
right you don't need the degree to be
successful it doesn't determine your
success you do so great reminder there
and uh if you guys want to make a hard
conversation about college easier go
watch borrowed future it's the
documentary that we put out it won a
webby award for best long-form
documentary and it's 88 minutes long and
i promise you if you sit down with your
kid and watch this they're going to be
the ones with questions going well is
that is that true how does that work we
need to talk about how we're doing this
we got to get a plan i'm not going to go
into student loan debt
it is that good and so make sure you go
check it out uh watch it over the
weekend with your kid as we head into
school season how is it already back to
school it's insane wild here we are
whenever they see whenever they see a
doctor
crying because of student loan debt
that's pretty awesome when he squealed
oh my i won't spoil her no spoiler alert
but there it is well tied to that
christina there's this article that our
producer james shared from yahoo nearly
three-quarters of millennials are more
than a hundred thousand dollars in debt
most not from mortgages
recession inflation's out-of-reach
housing market millennials are no
strangers to financial anxiety a
recently published report by the site
real estate which shows that most
members of the net generation are also
saddled with huge amounts of debt it
found that most of them have over a
hundred thousand worth of debt with most
of it not connected to a mortgage almost
half of them reported having some form
of student loans with the average person
owing a hundred twenty seven thousand
dollars but the most common type of debt
was credit card debt with uh two thirds
having some amount of debt on a credit
card
and while most millennials have accrued
a large amount of debt the bulk of them
63 believe they can pay it off over the
next one to five years only ten percent
said they never had debt and so this is
what we're seeing the reason one of the
reasons this generation is frustrated
and rightfully so is because they feel
like they were lied to they feel like
they just got screwed and they went well
mom and dad got a house and a car for
two thousand dollars and a bushel of
raspberries and i'm over here and that
average house is 400 grand and college
costs 80 grand a year i can't breathe
it's a huge problem it's a huge problem
i know i've heard a lot of the
frustration and just how it feels like
the line has moved it feels like it used
to be somewhere that seemed attainable
for them and then they're watching it
move but i think one of the biggest
challenges is not getting lost in that
feeling of desperation or hopelessness
because we're still seeing all sorts of
millennials pay off debt pay off all
their debt and buy houses and pay off
houses so yes being millennials
obviously yes we're we're seeing this
and um i'm in the housing market i'm
frustrated with it too um but you got to
keep that hope up because we are seeing
evidence constantly that even though it
is frustrating to see the market change
so much and move and feel like we got
people got lied to about student loans
and all of that
that is that's frustrating but there's
still hope yes we can't just sit here
with pessimism and sarcasm and and funny
mean tweets about how life sucks we have
to move on we've got to get a new
picture for what our life is going to
look like we got to stop comparing
ourselves to our parents which by the
way took them 25 years to get to where
they are today and you're not gonna get
there tomorrow so we gotta have some
delayed gratification we gotta have some
patience we've gotta stop looking at
instagram and going well i'll never be
enough and look at that house i want
that house today sorry buddy the fomo is
real get there it's gonna take longer
than you would like but this plan is the
best path to do it the baby steps it
works i've done it christina's done it
and there is hope for you america that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to my co-host christina
ellis austin ben james zack andrew in
the booth keeping this show afloat in
you america we love you we appreciate
you listening we'll be back with you
very soon
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by christina ellis and we are here to
take your calls about life and money the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
tyler kicks us off this hour in atlanta
tyler welcome to the show
thank you for taking my call yeah sure
what's going on
i have a question about some collections
okay on how to pay them off
all right how many uh bills do you have
in collections
uh it's about ten and the total is about
nineteen thousand
nineteen thousand what kind of debt is
this
uh
medical bills student loans uh we're
from a credit union that i loaned out in
after i graduated high school
a few old car loans and a few personal
loans okay
and what got you to this point have you
uh when was the last time you paid on
these and what made you stop
uh never paid on them
you never never made a single payment on
any of this
no did you have intention to
oh yes of course of course and what
happened
i
just
didn't get around to it forgot all about
it then i started getting them in the
mail i was like okay i need to start
paying these and i just want to know
which one should i do first
well have they been contacting you for a
while now are these old
oh yeah they're very old some like five
years old six years old
seven years old
okay well number one we've gotta be
proactive and get in touch with them and
communicate
but they haven't been knocking down your
door calling you any of that
oh no just i got a few letters in the
mail a couple a couple days ago and i
said i need to start paying them okay
and i totaled them all down and yeah is
that all of your the debt that you have
currently the 19 000
yes what do you do for a living
real estate okay how old are you
26.
all right what's your income
about 150. 150. so you could pay this
debt off pretty fast
yeah the real value what's holding you
back
uh i don't know which order to do them
in if it is an ordering to do it like uh
the ramsey way well we have the debt
snowball method which means you're
paying them off smallest to largest
okay so that's one way to do it to knock
it out and make some progress
okay should i add them in the uh monthly
budget absolutely are any of these
federal student loans
no uh it was just one big one it was
like 3 000 from my local credit union
okay do you have any money in savings
any money what's your liquid cash total
liquid cash about
ten thousand
okay
is investment
investments are they retirement or
non-retirement
retirement is a roth ira okay it's all
retirement okay and where is the 150
going each month
uh you said you're doing a budget
no not really okay we're gonna help you
with that for sure because you have a
great income there's no reason to to be
in debt you can pay cash for all of
these things going forward and clean up
this mess
do you feel any shame or guilt about
those past decisions and not paying them
i feel guilty yeah most definitely
because it should have been down by now
yeah i think that's part of the reason
you've ignored it
yeah right
let's put it in the drunk drawer and
let's not worry about that until someone
comes knocking
right right right you're absolutely
right well i think the best thing for
your future is to clean up this mess and
never look back and never touch debt
again you have a fantastic income you
got a bright future ahead of you and
those debts they don't define you
right
that's not who you are
tyler's a man of his word he's a man who
pays his bills on time he's a man who
pays cash for things and so i want you
to have that in your mind of the guy
that you're becoming and the identity
that you want to have going forward and
part of that is communicating with the
all the collections agencies and going
hey listen i'm sorry i haven't paid this
i'm ready to make good please confirm
the debt amounts uh i need proof of all
the debts that i have out there and i
will pay them
and then get on a plan
because right now you got 10k out of the
19. uh if you're following the baby
steps that means a thousand dollar
starter emergency fund which means
you've got 9 000 to throw this debt you
can cut it in half today
okay and you might be able to negotiate
the medical debt down and there may be
statutes of limitations but it's all
going to include you being real
intentional and doing your homework and
getting on the phone and sending some
emails and being proactive
and it's going to feel so good once
you've done that especially it's 19k and
you make 150 you can knock this out
quickly and the amount of peace you're
gonna find from just getting these
little ankle biters out of your life
it's like you will be able to just take
a a deep breath and not feel like
they're kind of haunting you like you
said they're like in the junk drawer
where you don't really want to see them
but you know that they're there and you
feel a lot of shame and guilt around
them well i think within easily six
months you could have these completely
knocked out and be building your
emergency fund and moving on to truly
being wealth and just have a completely
different outlook on your finances
so tyler your take-home pay based on
some rough numbers i'm guessing it's
about eight or nine thousand when you
average it out
on average yeah that's about average
money right so how quickly can we save
up the other 10 000 and knock this out
we're talking three months max
yeah i was um thinking before um
thanksgiving i like that i love that
that's gonna give you a lot to be
thankful for but here's what this means
it means we're pausing investing it
means we're not eating out we're gonna
look at every single dollar coming in
we're gonna give it a plan and that's
why i want you to start doing a budget
i'm going to gift you every dollar
premium
which will connect to your bank it'll
bring all the transactions in and your
job is to have your income on one side
and all of your expenses on the other
and you make a plan and then you're
gonna take out eating out take out
investments take out subscriptions for a
short season while we clean up this mess
and it's gonna you're gonna be there
faster than you know it
[Music]
okay i also have another question
exactly
um about person in the
house when should i start that after
paying off everything right
pay off everything then you're going to
build a three to six month emergency
fund
i would lean towards six months just so
you have a lot of financial peace in
your life because you haven't had that
with all this debt hanging around your
neck
and once you have six months of expenses
not income but expenses then we can
begin the process of saving up a down
payment for the house and i want you to
do it the smart way you're in real
estate so you know this process
right but also real estate agents can
make some bad decisions too can't they
they absolutely can i'm an example
so here's what i want you to do don't
buy the craziest nicest house and don't
take all the money the bank will give
you do it the smart way i want you to do
a 15-year fixed-rate conventional
mortgage
and i want the payment to be no more
than
a quarter of your take-home pay so we
mentioned let's say it's eight grand
we're talking two thousand dollars a
month on a 15-year mortgage and then
that'll dictate how much down payment
you need to save up but making 150k
you might be able to do this by the end
of next year have your own place with no
debt with a giant pile of cash in the
bank how would that feel that was the
goal that's the plan absolutely dude we
are cheering you on hang on the line our
friend austin will pick up on top of
every dollar premium i'm gonna gift you
financial peace university i want you to
watch all of those videos it's gonna
give you a lot of language and
confidence and education and motivation
you need to actually do this stuff to
make the sacrifices for a short season
so you can win for the rest of your life
we are here for you man thanks so much
for the call thanks for trusting us with
this situation we appreciate you this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
well august is national make a will
month i'm sure you already knew that
you've been celebrating for years but if
you didn't you're welcome
if you don't have an up-to-date will as
part of your estate plan what are you
waiting for you got to knock this out
now but here's the thing there's more to
estate planning than just having a will
estate planning covers all the documents
plans and conversations you need
to have in case something happens to you
and no you don't have to be an eccentric
millionaire with an offshore account to
have an estate plan
so that means you need an estate plan
and a good estate plan protects your
family's future and it's easy to put
yours together with the right tools and
we can help start by checking out our
estate planning guide it's completely
free it's easy to use and it will help
you keep track of everything you need
it'll walk you through which documents
to get like your will if you don't have
one what conversations to have and where
you can go to get more information so
you can knock this stuff off of your
list
give yourself and your loved ones peace
of mind by figuring this stuff out ahead
of time download our complete guide to
estate planning for free at
slash estate guide that's ramsey
solutions dot com slash estate guide
joseph joins us up next he's in new york
city joseph welcome to the show
thank you thank you very much how can we
help today
uh my question uh is regarding a
mortgage issue uh and investing uh
for
the last 10 years or so
i refinanced about 10 years ago
and i've been a very disciplined
investor since um roughly about 16 18
years old uh
my financial planner back in 2012
recommended that since i'm such a
disciplined investor take advantage of
having a third year mortgage at 3.2
percent
rather than
going with a 15-year mortgage uh and he
recommended that i reinvest
what i would have sunken into my home he
considered my house a losing investment
and he said i'd probably be better off
uh investing over the long run uh the
difference between the payments uh i've
done so over the years over the last 10
years and in addition to that i've
built a net equity of close to three
million dollars good for you
so my question to you is it basically uh
goes against uh what dave kind of says
uh with paying off your house first um
whereas i'm gonna i'm in a position
where i have 20 years left on my
mortgage
uh and a thousand dollars my mortgage
payment every month is not going away if
i
if i pay off the mortgage because that's
property taxes uh something obviously we
can't get rid of
but only the 900 principle that i would
have left in my pocket at the end of the
month i've been sinking uh into mutual
funds and investments
which since 2012 since refinance have
grown uh roughly at about 12 to 13
average
over that time
so my question is uh you know am i wrong
for doing such
or um
should i be sitting here writing a check
out for the balance of my home which i
just kind of have a hard time doing uh
taking out of investments to pay my home
loss
well joseph uh you know our answer and
that's to stroke that check and pay off
the house today i don't think you're
gonna do that and that's okay you've
done really well for yourself and you're
right there's a lot of ways to make
money and there's a lot of rich people
out there who didn't follow the baby
steps so is there a way to build wealth
without following the baby steps
absolutely can you leverage debt and
build wealth
you've done it so you're living proof
that it can be done
but the issue is that it always works
until it doesn't
and uh clearly you're very disciplined
like you've mentioned you don't seem
like the type to get greedy and make
poor decisions when it comes to
investing
is that right correct that that's
correct i aside from my mortgage i do
have a
a car payment as well i believe at three
percent interest and again i i just had
a hard time sitting there i do have the
money but i just had a hard time taking
it out of investments because i've been
such a disciplined investor and my you
know historical uh historical rates on
the market investments have
have exceeded this three percent so
you know i'm not one to run into debt
i'm very disciplined i don't let my
credit card go over a thousand dollars
without paying it off the end of the
month um but i do carry the car and the
mortgage which i just have it's a hard
kill to swallow writing those big checks
and taking the money out of investments
sure yeah that is hard because you
always want to see that money grow when
you're heavy on the investment side
you're like well i could be doing better
in the market right
until the market isn't doing better and
you don't have money to cover an
emergency
and so that's where things get dicey how
old are you
where it does come down to the emergency
um i do have uh you know income wise
between my wife and i would make about
350 000 a year a little bit over a
hundred thousand of it is a guaranteed
uh pension for life so i'm already
retired from my first my first career um
so
i can live off of that alone but you
know my new job i'm making over a
hundred thousand with that one as well
so
uh i do have six months in cash
uh in a safe uh
of emergency money uh which i don't even
think about you know i thought about the
uh what dave had said to the woman
putting it in her picture frame uh i
keep it in my safe which is great i
don't even think about it uh so other
than the car and the mortgage you have
the money in your safe at home
correct why not have it in a bank
uh
well
good question
well i just because you're so hot on you
know i want this money to grow but then
you're letting this money not even keep
up with inflation over here so i was
just confi i was just curious
well you know i figured hey thirty forty
thousand dollars whether it fits in a
bank account i'm not even well yeah it's
a chump change to you you guys are doing
so great financially making 350k a year
so you can out earn any level of
inflation and poor decisions out there
so here's the truth richard you're uh or
joseph you are uh you're an exception to
the rule with a crazy income and you've
done well over the years how old are you
48
48. so you've been in this game for 30
years
yes i've been in it for 30 years and i i
started out when i was basically 16
years old with about 500 and
as soon as i had the opportunity to max
out my first 401k i did for 25 years
and uh in addition to that i
i sunk as much money as i possibly can
make into some mutual funds discipline
taken out of my account every month for
the last 30 years and that's hence it
grew
into roughly three million dollars
yeah well i mean that's fantastic you
guys are going to live a great life
in retirement and you're not even close
to it yet so
here's the thing i'm looking at your
picture and i wish i could meet joseph
and put them next to each other like
bizarro joseph who said i'm not going to
touch debt at 16
and i'm going to put all of my income
working for me i'm never going to go
into debt i'm never going to get a car
loan i'm going to get a 15-year mortgage
and pay it off as fast as i can
and i just am very curious if that
joseph would have a higher net worth
than 3 million dollars 30 years later
what do you think
i i i don't know i don't feel as if uh
unless my income was much higher uh i
don't feel that i i could have or we
could have done much better
uh i feel you know i've gotten
compliments from my current financial
planner and she you know she uses me as
stories to others
who struggle you know with debt and so
forth and it's it's actually a matter of
just being disciplined yeah you know
going out to eat every single night the
week doesn't work you know sure and i
think that's honestly that's been your
saving grace is you've been so so
disciplined that you've been able to
handle it i'm not mad at that you know
to each his own everyone's got their own
plan this is the plan that's worked for
me and the ramsay plan is the one that's
worked for millions of people and uh
they can do it regardless of their
income so
making 350 000
you're gonna be okay you've got a great
net worth you've done well but we just
believe that the borrower saved slave to
the lender it's an old biblical
principle from proverbs and because of
that it changes our value system it
changes the way we make decisions it
changes my identity when i decide i'm
just going to be a guy who doesn't touch
debt i'm going to be a guy who has the
discipline to pay cash and not owe
anyone anything and as dr john deloney
says there's a physical weight with debt
and i already don't sleep well i can't
imagine having debt hanging over my neck
on top of that
but i hope you're sleeping well and
you've got a great net worth a great
income you're doing fine and for every
joseph you know there's there's 10 000
more who are trying to be joseph who are
making very poor decisions who are broke
and those are the people i'm trying to
help you know i'm i'm here for those uh
that need the help and you my friend you
truly don't you're doing great but let
me just say every financial advisor is
going to tell you to do a 30 over 15 so
that you can give them more money to
invest so a little biased on that side
but more power to you man thanks for the
call a fun discussion this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by christina ellis
hey folks if you didn't know we do this
show live on the glass and you can come
watch us like zoo animals it's a good
time and i love meeting people we come
out there twice an hour to greet folks
take pictures sign things and it's a
blast so if you're in the nashville area
or you plan on heading this way
make it a point to stop by we've got
free baked goods free coffee a free
ramsey show mug you can take a picture
on the debt free stage it's a good time
there's a whole
fan experience you can walk through a
timeline wall of the history of this
place
we try to make it very inviting to our
guests so that's my invitation to you as
we head back to school
coffee's the best mostly because we're
lonely not a lot of people out there
today christina
and the coffee is good and it's even
better when it's free yes there we go
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five danielle is
in jackson mississippi danielle welcome
to the show
uh hi thanks for having me sure how can
we help
um so my dad passed away two years ago
and gave
us a family inheritance of about a
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
so we are debt-free and all we have left
to pay is our home mortgage which we got
at like a three percent interest
um and so
being debt
and having this kind of money we already
have an emergency fund set aside so
we're trying to figure out where to plug
this money in should we put it on our
home to begin the payoff for it or
should we make some investments
we're just trying to see where to go
from here
how much do you have left on your home
about 193 000
and do you have kids
we do we have four all right party what
ages um six five three and a two month
old that is quite the party you got your
hands full i'm surprised you had time to
make this call
well i got my five and six-year-old
babysitting the babies oh good good good
okay well there's there's only three
things you can do with money and i think
it's uh amazing that you were left this
legacy in this blessing uh but i am so
sorry for for your loss
thank you so when it comes to the baby
steps you guys are in four through six
currently
so that means we're investing 15 percent
of our income into retirement are you
currently doing that
uh yes okay
next would be saving for college and so
you could put a chunk of that maybe you
throw you know five or ten grand for
each kid into a 529 or an esa that could
be an option
okay to kick start that do you have
anything safe for college currently
uh we haven't started that yet no okay
are there any upcoming repairs
renovations car upgrades you guys need
to make
um my husband may need to make some type
of upgrade on a vehicle because he's our
zero um one income family
so he's our workhorse so he might um
we might be needing some type of small
use something to get him back and forth
to work soon okay so i would get a very
reasonable commuter vehicle this is not
the time to get you know the ford f-150
uh new on the lot because you got this
pile of cash
right so you could upgrade the car put
some towards college if you wanted to
fully fund you know a roth ira for the
year you could do that as well and then
whatever's left over i'm throwing at the
mortgage
okay
so that's how i see it just filter it
through those baby steps and of course
you can you know there's only three
things you can do with money in general
which is give save and spend you guys
already have the emergency fund and
you're already on track for investing
and so you could give a little as well
uh if you're part of a local church you
could tithe some of that money or if
there's an offering that's something
you're passionate about you could give
to that but otherwise maybe you take
some of it and spend it would your dad
have wanted that
for you to enjoy it
well he was he was very much a debt-free
guy and
he was all about not owning anybody and
so
i'm kind of wanting to keep that that
legacy alive which we don't owe anybody
and throw it to the house make daddy
proud
awesome well thank you all so much
absolutely thank you so much for the
call yeah that's a beautiful way to
honor him just knowing that that's
something that he valued and treasured
and for you to keep keep that legacy
alive is amazing one other thought is
just making sure i don't know where you
are with your emergency fund if you have
three or six months but just making sure
too that that's really beefed up being a
one-income family um just making sure
that you have that extra layer of
security so that you know you can make
sure if a big thing happens that you
avoid that debt and with four kids with
poor can who knows
that's a lot of life that's gonna happen
with those kids and they're all gonna go
to college debt free that's my hope for
them and i think you guys are on track
to do that and pretty soon you're not
gonna have a mortgage i mean that'll
really kick-start this journey and
they'll they might be debt-free within a
year or two completely that's beautiful
and just such an amazing way to make
your dad proud yes thanks so much for
the call danielle josh joins us up next
in birmingham josh welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call absolutely
um i'm
i'm calling because uh
my wife and i just are in the early
stages of the baby steps
um and just got introduced to the ramsey
stuff
welcome to the club
thank you
um
we just kind of just wanted to call and
kind of see about some some fundamentals
like some first steps what some
practical
and practical ways to get us jump
started on this
absolutely so how much debt do you guys
have
uh we've got about
right at right at 50
to 55. okay what kind of debt
uh 11 000 is my student loans uh 20 26
000
is a car
and we've got 4 000 in credit card
and
i i think that's about it
okay it's not adding up to 55. looks
like there's something missing there
i'm getting about 41 based on the
numbers you just threw at me
is there another dead in the picture
not that i'm not that i can think of
right now okay what's your income
uh so i just i just changed to a new job
and i'm going to be making
uh
about
45
000 initially okay
a year but then
you know in about two months they're
going to transition me
uh and the low end is going to be about
58k
and then my wife makes about 12 000 to
15 000 a year working part-time okay is
she home with the kiddos
uh yeah when she's not at work okay how
many kids you got
two we just had twin girls last
september oh that's sweet do you guys
have another car
uh it is but yes it's paid off though
what's that car worth
um
i paid 4 000 for it and it's yeah i
probably wouldn't get that out of it
it's just my you know get to work car
okay
i'm just looking at that car loan going
that feels like a lot of car
for your income
and i'm wondering if you could sell it
and make a net profit and clean up this
debt a lot faster and get something more
reasonable right now
uh i took it by a dealership last
weekend and they valued it about 4 000
lower than what we owe
uh sounds like a dealership and
yeah so
i would be checking facebook marketplace
carvana vroom
uh craigslist autotrader and maybe kelly
blue book as well and get a real value
for that because the dealership's trying
to make money and so they're trying to
get it at a deal so they can sell it for
more and make profit so that might be an
option for you but you're asking for
tips on how to do this plan and the
number one tip is to stop the bleeding
and don't go into debt anymore
number two is to get on a tight budget
every single month and i'm going to help
you with that by gifting you every
dollar premium which will connect to
your bank account
and number three
uh get your wife on the same page are
you guys pumped up about getting out of
debt
uh yeah yeah we both we both kind of
recognize that there's a there's a
problem and we want to be able to set up
our girls to
to you know go to school and and you
know i listen to the show often so that
means you have a strong why my friend
you look into those little girls eyes
and say they're never going to know debt
as they grow up and they're gonna watch
their dad and their mom sacrifice to
avoid owing anyone anything and so hang
on the line austin's gonna pick up we're
gonna gift you every dollar premium to
start your written budget do that
together you and your wife and i'm gonna
gift you financial peace university
watch all of those videos and stop going
into debt make a plan using the debt
snowball list your debts smallest to
largest let's get our incomes up as much
as we can and call us back when you are
completely debt free and do a debt-free
scream can't wait for it thanks so much
for the call josh appreciate you
listening appreciate you joining this
club of weirdos who believe that you can
live without payments this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 6 33-34
but seek first his kingdom and his
righteousness and all these things will
be provided to you so do not worry about
tomorrow for tomorrow we'll worry about
itself each day has enough trouble of
its own
ain't that the truth
that that advice holds true today mark
twain once said the fear of death
follows from the fear of life a man who
lives fully is prepared to die at any
time
some rock and roll words from mark twain
there
caitlyn joins us up next in west palm
beach caitlin welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely what's going on
so i am 26 i'm finally being able to
move out of my parents place or at least
attempting to
i own my own mobile grooming dog
business i'm trying to sell and move out
of the state to get away from my
helicopter parent
all right do you have to go that far
this is a situation
i'm running
oh my goodness okay
so i don't know
how much i should be saving to go into
it
you're breaking up on us caitlin you got
a bad connection there oh
you can uh can hear me yes that's better
okay
um i'm just not sure
what i should do when i don't know how
much my bills are going to be i don't
know i'm going into a state that i have
no friends at
why are you moving to that state
i'm trying to move over to um
chattanooga but i'm trying to get out of
florida
watch out
because that's where um
i used to i had a friend there um so
we're reconnecting there
but it just seems more of a a nicer
place than a little less expensive in
florida too in
palm beach county okay yeah we're just
curious out of all the places i mean
we're big fans of tennessee chattanooga
is wonderful but it just seemed like
you're just running like chattanooga is
the place and i don't know why because i
don't know anyone there
yeah i have that one friend now but
that's about it okay and you're gonna
restart your mobile grooming business
over there is that the plan
no i'm actually selling everything and
i'm going it getting my cdl and going
truck driving so completely different
wow
what kind of eat pray love journey are
you on caitlyn what's going on your life
this is a complete 180.
when
my parents are very um
they're they were helicopter parents so
i always worked for either my dad's
company and then i started my own but
they would never let me get out of the
house take the thing
well i just want you to run
i want you running to something instead
of away from something
i want you to be excited about the move
instead of an urgent i gotta get out of
here and i gotta move across the country
and switch careers that's just a lot of
stress to deal with
why why why do you want to be a truck
driver
a little bit better money than what i'm
right now
how much do you charge for mobile
grooming
what's the average cost for a dog
um anywhere from
uh 60 to 140.
so 140 bucks a dog
and it's not enough to cover the bills
based on how many clients you have is
that the issue
clients and also overhead with gas
prices the insurance
um the van payment itself is
1700
okay
how long have you been thinking about
making this transition
about two years now
okay
and do you
how do you think your parents will react
to it
um i'm not sure
so you haven't broken the news to them
that you're going to head out
no i'm just kind of going to say merry
christmas i'm gone
wow
well you asked that's gonna be the
easiest way you asked us how much money
you need saved and you don't have much
clarity on what your bills are going to
be but are you in debt right now
yeah i'm about 110 000 in debt but when
i sell the business it should be about
120 that i get out so i'll have at least
ten thousand through that and on top of
about a ten thousand that i can save are
you sure you're going to find a buyer to
give you 120 000 in cash to buy a mobile
grooming business
i already have um somebody lined up for
december wow that's fantastic okay
so if i'm in your shoes that debt is
gone and i have ten thousand dollars in
the bank this was your get out of jail
free card
yeah
and that's exactly what's going to
prepare you for whatever season is next
is having no debt and a pile of money
regardless
of it
do you think that about 20 000 should be
good going into something like this
again i have no experience with it yeah
i mean you're going to have moving costs
so just look at logistically yeah i'm
going to have to rent somewhere there
may be a deposit involved i'm going to
have moving costs i'm going to need to
buy some things for the new place
depending on what i take with me and
what i don't
um and so look at all that and we got to
figure out what does the education look
like to get the cdl have you done that
yet
yes i already know where i'm going to be
going to it's a four week course how
much does that cost
about four thousand okay so we're going
to cash flow that
yeah so we need at least four 000 plus
our emergency fund plus moving expenses
plus plus plus so i would start making a
list of what that looks like and see how
quickly i can save that up so that i'm
not in a bind when we move and we go oh
gosh i don't have the four grand oh gosh
i don't have the moving expenses
okay but i do want you to think on it
because i want you to think long and
hard about just all of the decisions and
to take a pause and a deep breath and go
is this the right place is this the
right career path and think long and
hard about it i'm going to give you some
tools to help you with that
number one is own your past change your
future it sound that's from dr john
delony and it sounds like you've you've
had
quite the struggle at home with the
parents
and you got to deal with that because
you go with you and so if we don't deal
with this trauma it's going to resurface
wherever we find ourselves in whatever
career we go so that book's going to
help with that and then on the career
side i'm going to send you our friend
ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose which will help you figure out
what that sweet spot is for you between
your talent your passion and your
mission and maybe it's truck driving but
from what i heard from you you were
stepping into it because of the pay bump
and i'm i'm guaranteeing you're a
talented person you're dealing with
people you've run a business there's a
lot of things you can do and i want to
make sure that we put all the options on
the table before we jump into this yeah
you've just been through such a huge
transition and you're going to go into a
huge transition and i would just
encourage you to breathe i know it's a
lot it's hard when you're dealing with a
traumatic past when you're dealing with
helicopter parents when there's a lot
going on but like george said own your
past change your future take the time to
invest in yourself in this process i
know that you're going to be plowing
ahead and that's you know you're seeking
a healthier environment or space where
you can grow but make sure in that
process that you take time for you to
really work through your past to work
through everything that you've been
through because a lot of times when
we're you know mucked up with a really
messy past it's hard to really see
clearly and to know what to do in your
future especially if you're moving
forward out of fear or out of trauma you
know that can be really hard so maybe
even before you make such big decisions
just take a little bit of time to do
some soul searching and to take a pause
to deal with some of what you've been
through yeah okay and truck driving is a
hard business have you talked to anyone
in the truck driving business to see
what that's like
from what i gathered you're breaking up
but it sounded like your uncle's in the
business and you've spoken to him i
might do a little more digging talk to a
few more people because long term that's
a hard hard thing to do for a long
period of time
and i want you to sink your teeth into
something that you can put the next 10
you're 26 years old you've got another
35 years of your career and i want you
to pour it into something that really
gives you meaning and purpose and joy
that you can sustain and that might be
truck driving i don't know but it sounds
like so far we're just running away from
and just looking at the next thing what
can i do where can i go and it's out of
desperation instead of out of
intentionality and uh you know we say no
one makes good decisions when they're
panicked or drunk and you sound panicked
i don't think you're drunk so that's
good news we got we're one for two here
but i want you to do it with wisdom and
intentionality and with some pause
and slow down and so hang on the line
austin is going to pick up
and he's going to send you own your past
change your future by dr john doloni and
from paycheck to purpose by ken coleman
uh and i i think that's good anything
else we can just keep giving her things
all day long christina i think that's
great and then also just in this process
make a plan like especially when you're
dealing with trauma and fear and just
all the confusion of leaving a really
messy situation facts are your friends
take the time to kind of lay things out
make a written budget you know we can
gift her every dollar premium to perfect
really the trifecta there we go get
everything written on paper so you can
see it clearly and kind of
get through the confusion of all of it
love it thank you so much for the call
caitlyn wishing the best for you that
puts this hour of the ramsay show in the
books my thanks to my fantastic co-host
christina ellis all the folks in the
booth austin ben and james and zach and
andrew and bobby and you america we
appreciate you listening in until next
time spend wisely save intentionally and
give generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you